everyone agrees that education
is hugely important the thing is we're
not particularly sure what we want from
it
the aim of education should be to
prepare us for the challenges of adult
life
yet from this perspective it's clear
that schools fail
all but a tiny portion of their students
whether in highly academic private
schools
or in deprived government-run ones
trouble dealing with life's challenges
remains very widespread indeed
human ingenuity energy good will and
talent
is being lost on an industrial scale
to get more ambitious about education
doesn't necessarily mean
spending more money building more
schools employing more teachers or
making exams more difficult
rather it should mean focusing more on
the real purpose of education
there are two fundamental tasks it
should help us with
working and sustaining good
relationships in order to address these
needs
a future national curriculum might
specify that the following subjects be
studied
firstly capitalism a conspiracy of
silence exists around the economic
system we live within
we find it hard to change its bad sides
or defend its strengths
because we simply don't fully understand
how it works
a subject like maths should be geared to
teaching its number one utility
for 99 of the population dealing with
money such classes would demystify the
global economy
by teaching students the importance of
the means of production
and how profits are made the role of
cash flow hr leadership marketing and
competition
would also be studied in the perfect
school system
you'd also then study a really big
second subject
yourself young students would be
introduced to the idea that we humans
are extremely prone to misunderstanding
ourselves
they would be taken through the concept
of delusion defensiveness projection and
denial in everyday life
individual tutors would be on hand to
help students draw personality maps
with particular attention paid to their
neuroses and fears
doing this would ensure that students
learn a lot about how complex they truly
are
and what types of people they would be
best suited to hang out with
a crucial unit would be devoted to
career self-knowledge
what job are you best suited to students
would spend three hours a week exploring
what they might do with their futures
then one would study relationships being
intensely aware of the social and
individual cost of every unhappy
relationship an ideal education system
would emphasize the acquisition of
skills
that help people to live better together
there would be units on
kindness and forgiveness as well as on
anxiety reduction techniques
in this educational utopia it wouldn't
only be children who would go to school
but adults as well schooling would be
for life
education wouldn't just be taking place
in classrooms
media and the arts would be made to
maximize their teaching potential
and help to teach people what they
actually need to learn
we're so hung up on the challenges of
running a massive education system
with failing to pinpoint the real source
of its problems
these aren't primarily about money
salaries or discipline
these are really only a consequence of a
more fundamental problem
right now and with no one quite meaning
for this to happen
we've simply got the wrong curriculum
hmm